so it's safe spaces spread throughout
our college campuses are such places
getting any safer not from the walking
brain-dead that's for sure a new study
shows that as badly educated far-left
activists continue to label words as
violence and ideas is not wrong but evil
they've helped turn arenas of free
thought into monuments to the East
German secret police the new study found
that a quarter of students believe you
can silence views that they don't like
and it's okay to obstruct the speakers
in order to do so six times as many
liberals felt that way as non lives and
while nearly all conservatives said that
they would be friends with a liberal a
large minority of lives wouldn't
reciprocate no wonder 70 percent of
conservatives fear expressing their
views in class so this is where you send
your kids not to be educated but to be
indebted no longer to engage but to
punish each other it's a place where its
gatekeepers realize the only way to
preserve their bad ideas is to enlist
zombies students to cooperate against
their rebellious peers like guards in a
prison camp
does this help shape young minds well if
those minds can be found they can
certainly be shaped into what one
wonders
[Applause]
[Music]
are those healthy minds are they people
you can work with upon graduation hell
no you don't want to be around that to
them community empathy skepticism
nonconformity and free thought are
oppressive where once parents sent their
kids to college to be educated now
they're sending them to be
institutionalized
it's a Cuckoo's Nest and the lunatics
are coming for you all right
Geraldo you were you were a young dude
in the sixties is this different are
these like was there more intelligence
and it was pretty rough in the sixties
but I mean it was pretty intolerant they
know like where you see people like that
I I think it sticks out more because we
haven't we've had a couple of decades of
gentility hmm so we're shocked but it
was pretty raw during Vietnam and the
end of civil rights it was pretty rose
to racial thing when it's pretty real I
just want to say that the only thing
more difficult socially than being a
conservative is being a moderate these
days I call myself roadkill I get it
from the left I get it from the right
and our old boss Roger Ailes used to say
the only thing in the middle of the road
is roadkill so I'm roadkill yeah that's
just a lost cause for free thought
should we just create our own maybe yeah
I mean Prager you certainly did I hope
not though and you know I grew up
without social media without the
internet and you Amish growing up you
know I grew up in the Bay Area in
Berkeley and my teachers everybody they
were all you know still practicing and
hippies from the 60s and they totally
fostered my then goals of being an Air
Force fighter pilot and I loved all that
stuff and I felt like this just makes me
so sad to see especially in Berkeley
because I grew up in such a different
environment even though all around me
were people who felt so differently
supported and in law school as president
of the Federalist Society in San
Francisco where my whole role was
bringing the other view to debates I
never got any crap for it it was it was
support it and I'm not trying to paint
this rosy existence but just that that
was our reality my best friend from home
goes to a revolutionary meeting every
Sunday and it's all fine but now for
some reason I don't know if it's the
amplification from social media or the
the different times whatever it is but
it certainly doesn't feel like it used
to Dana you were in The Weather
Underground a lot of people don't know
that but no but I'm sort to her I think
it's it used to be you could actually
have a conversation is it because I
think it's the identity politics and the
intersectionality has created an
oppressor versus oppressed and social
media to the mix and that it's very
combustible and then it's also viral so
then we all see it
I have friends whose kids are getting
ready to go to college and there they
really are at a loss they don't know
what to do they're super worried about
it they want their kids to be able to do
go to a good place it's interesting
though because the increase in tuition
you can almost track with the increase
of these incidents there's a place like
Purdue University where former governor
mitch Daniels is the president they just
announced I think it was yesterday their
ninth consecutive tuition freeze Wow and
there's like using free-market
principles like figure it out a way to
do something really smart and there are
universities like that but they're the
exception well I'm gonna start buying
their chicken so Jesse you have
daughters that are gonna be in about a
decade
college-bound are you going is this
gonna bother you are you gonna
homeschool better school no I have
liberal friends and I have conservative
friends and it's great because when we
all get together we all just make fun of
the Liberals yes and that's what Gigan
college is about you have a few drinks
and then you bust the chops of people
you disagree with and it sharpens your
skills and then if you date a
conservative is great too because then
they can just pay for dinner it is
interesting because hard times do make
people more tolerant but it's such a
it's such a luxury for these kids to be
we have known the courtyard for you
should eat your own